why don't we go next to
oh you know who i want to speak to
hey snake from moscow welcome are you
there
hi can you hear me yeah you know snake
people in the audience were worried
about you
because we learned last week or the week
before
that a russian teacher
had been
prosecuted and sentenced for telling her
students
uh her view on what's going on in russia
and you and i when we last spoke you
said if the if the government figured
out who you were you're a teacher as
well that it could be very bad for you
but i'm so glad to find out that it is
not you that has been prosecuted and
sentenced
yeah unfortunately irene again has
received a five-year suspended sentence
yeah what makes this particular case
very heartbreaking is that
basically during the
uh i think it's called the discovery
stage of the case it was found out that
a group of eighth graders that she was
teaching they basically goaded her and
provoked her into that type of
conversation and then they submitted
the recording of that session with the
help of their parents
to the investigative committee of russia
which is
not great wow it's almost like
entrapment by by 13 year olds in a way
yeah i mean
people usually think that oh teenagers
they're just you know they're so
innocent but no some teenagers are not
benevolent they're outright malicious
and malevolent wow well what's on your
mind today snake
uh basically i just uh today is the
first day that uh i'm back on the server
and a bunch of people told me that you
all thought that i got arrested but no
i'm just down with covet again and oh
basically uh basically what i wanted to
tell you is a very
weird thing that has been happening in
the russian educational system when it
comes to higher education in
universities
this uh
this summer considering that they need
to
hold back the sympathies of all the
soldiers and all the policemen all of us
guardia russian government has created
special quotas for children family
members of those particular law
enforcement officers as well as special
quotas for
people that are being deported from
ukraine into russia basically it was a
card blanche that allowed people to
enroll into any university onto any
program without passing any type of
exams that would signify that a person
has graduated from school
so
43 000 or more such quotas were created
across russian universities
and considering just how lenient this
this admissions process is for such
people from those categories it's really
surprising that those quotas have not
been filled at all for example in my
university we received 150 such quotas
we had 120 applications and only over 90
people actually got enrolled huh and
what do you think is going on why why
are people not not attending
first and foremost
another thing you have to know about the
admissions process in russia is that you
register for the admission process using
your pension number so every person who
achieves a certain age receives a card
called snills which is your future
pension uh how how do you say
identification card for your pension
so it's very very easy to dox a person
if you take their uh pension id number
and then look through various government
registries so i think that a lot of
those people got really scared that they
will be really heavily doxxed and will
face some sort of retribution in the
society wow wow that's an incredible
situation snake one question for you i
recently finished reading an
extraordinary book by ben mcintyre about
a
russian
russian intelligence officer
who uh was spying
against russia for the uk named oleg
gordievsky is that a name you are
familiar with
unfortunately i'm not in that particular
period of historical studies but uh
i will try to email you if i find any
relevant information i'm very skeptical
of anybody that's a former spy because
spies can be bought and traded
on average oh yeah no this is a why it's
not uh no i'm not i'm just wondering if
it's like if people within russia know
about him because internationally his
story has been extensively documented
he's still alive i think he's in his 70s
but something to look into snake
yeah i will i will look so mcintyre on
gordianka right
uh yes oleg gordievsky is my anglicized
pronunciation of the gentleman's name
okay thank you all right snake from
moscow stay safe out there a lot
happening a lot a lot a lot happening
let's go next to guillaume from montreal
guillaume i am anxiously and imminently
waiting to go to montreal i will be
there very very soon
hey david do you hear me i can hear you
find guillaume
thank you david for having me
a big fan been a been following you for
the last two years i believe thank you
and quite frankly if you do have a visit
around montreal just
make sure to let us know what event it's
uh it's about and i'll try to attend
it's actually just visiting family is
what it is it's there's no events
planned right now people asked would i
be willing to do a montreal meetup
i would in theory uh but it's you know
it's a lot to plan as i'm sure you can
imagine
yeah that's definitely that definitely
is plus the venues tend to be a bit a
bit more on the expensive side and
everything really
anyway my question is a bit of a
hypothetical and with a bit of a
preamble but i think it's an interesting
question
to provoke thought
okay if we can limit the preamble
because there's 40 people waiting to
chat that would be great a little what
that actually helps keeping that as a
hypothetical okay instead of assuming
that i have a secret method or something
okay
so the hypothetical is let's say in a
random
uh thrift store you find a copy of the
us constitution and that by reading it
you are granted the power to add one
amendment to it to fix most of the issue
in the long run probably
that the us is having
what would be the amendment you would
magically add to the constitution
oh i have i am terrible at these things
i mean we have so many problems in this
country
i don't know that there's one i mean
maybe it would relate to the financing
of politics but i these questions are so
tough because they're so unrealistic and
so i i don't know i mean i think i would
i would uh declare myself dictator that
would be the one amendment that would
fix all of our problems guillaume i
don't know
i know i've i know i've been thinking
about it and one that have been floating
about in my friend group regarding that
was
uh essentially forcing
uh term limits on anything that holds a
position of power so senate yeah that
occurred to me term just term limit
everything yeah so at the end of the day
you if you want to buy a politician you
have to buy more than one per decade so
make it expensive to buy politicians now
that's an interesting one yeah let me
devote more thought to it and i'll come
back with something more substantive
all right well on that lovely note thank
you for the call that's that's the only
question i had so have a great day and
uh
thanks for the great show you put your
you provide on a daily basis thank you
so much there is guillaume from montreal
we are going to take a very brief break
if you're holding don't hang up because
we will be right back to the phones
momentarily